[Music]
all right welcome to session 303
Building Solutions was serverless on
kubernetes engine we actually wanted to
call this building solutions with cloud
run on gke but for obvious reasons we
didn't have that session title until
just now as I'm saying it so what we're
gonna be talking about is our new
offering cloud run gke and how you can
take advantage of it i'm donna melegari
I'm a product manager and Marc 20 I'm
one of the technical program managers
looking after service specifically
thinks on top of kubernetes all right so
let's talk about kubernetes it's really
fascinating kubernetes is basically
emerged as the de facto standard port
container orchestration you know it's
really picked up steam and people who've
been using other solutions are finding
kubernetes is great for their needs
which is awesome
and there's a huge ecosystem there's a
ton of companies building on it there's
jobs that are growing the staff that I
saw was the jobs are growing 250 percent
month-over-month and I think the real
test that a technology has taken off is
when recruiters ask for 10 years of
experience in it and of course
kubernetes annatto fit around not even
there aren't very few people who even
have 5 years experience in it but that's
how entrenched it's become people forget
how new it is so the very popularity
Donna was just talking about of
kubernetes is also driving a large
number of use cases growing number of
use cases that people try to use
kubernetes to address with that means
that today kubernetes is able to do the
container scheduling that was able to do
a day one but it's also able to do load
balancing and identity management and
authorization and many other services
that make the operator the kubernetes
operator experience very very friendly
their their work is made simpler a lot
they are Cabernets obfuscates a lot of
the complexity of the underlining
infrastructure from them so don't have
to worry about the VMS or
else's underneath and to large degree
even even better when you run on top of
manage kubernetes service like GK which
makes this whole experience is so much
better
so that ubiquity the the fact that
kubernetes is available pretty much in
every single cloud service provider
today it's hard to find one that does
not offer kubernetes service means that
developers are naturally interested in
their service but their experience is
not as smooth developers I believe - you
know on the end of the day they really
just want to write code just give me
something to write code and make sure
that it runs well developing directly on
top of kubernetes so if you're
developing your writing application Java
Go Python whatever it may be it's
possible and people do it and there's a
lot of tools around it and make it
possible but you have to stitch those
tools just right you have to make sure
that they work perfectly and there's a
lot of toil that's involved also in this
process so you have to besides just
building the images which at this point
frankly you know everybody does but
there's also you know exposing the
service to the outside world or managing
traffic and also to large degree
kubernetes is still optimized for batch
workloads which means which among many
other things means that it scales on CPU
for modern applications that that you're
writing today CPU scalability is
probably not the right way to do that
you're looking for low latency of
response you're looking for ability to
scale up and down and all of that is not
directly available to you as a as a
developer so modern modern stateless
application development on top of
kubernetes definitely could get better
and like to have done I'll tell us about
that so our solution to this is cloud
run this is the new product that we've
launched this week and we're bringing
serverless to containers so what does
that mean
now serverless is an interesting term
because of course it's a misnomer there
are obviously servers involved it's also
an interesting term when you talk about
a cluster that you manage yourself so
what we talked about is a serverless
developer experience if you use the
fully hosted cloud run which is the
default
if you go into the cloud room
console and create a service it's fully
serverless there are no cluster there's
no cluster to manage and you only pay
for what you use essentially we Google
cloud is your operator we're managing
all of that underlying infrastructure
for you now the reality is that when you
have a cloud vendor as your operator
there's a lot of assumptions that we
make that may not suit your needs and
that's where kubernetes comes in and
cloud run on gke
and what this means is if you use cloud
run NGK your operators have this great
kubernetes experience you can set up
role based access control networking
policies can decide what cluster you
want all that kind of stuff but
developers are abstracted from this and
they have a server list developer
experience that can scale up and down so
cloud or none gke compared to the fully
hosted cloud run gives you a lot more
flexibility of course there's more to
manage but if that's what you're already
intending to do it can be a great choice
if you already have gke cloud run and GK
is a great option so you have more
machine options you can run on GPUs you
can access more things that are
currently integrated with cloud right on
GK thanks so Donna has explained kind of
the differences between the two flavors
of cloud run the cloud run gives you the
consistent developer experience
regardless where you run it whether it's
not a managed service or on the cloud
run on gke
but coming back to the original picture
that we talked about when you when
developers use cloud run some of the
things that they had to do before still
happening there just happening behind
the scene and happen automatically or
they were made much easier so you
continue getting the very same power of
kubernetes underneath but you're able to
benefit from from a lot of automation
that cloud run on GK delivers to you and
what that means is that you you don't
have to focus as much on you know the
manuals that the shading Dayak so to
speak over and over
building these images there's way to
integrate other exposing the service to
the Internet and because cloud run is
supporting K native api's and more about
that later
you will be able to preserve that same
developer experience whether you run on
cloud run on GK cloud run hosted or
whether you run on top of another key
native compatible offering whether it's
on-premise that you're on yourself or
whether it's consumed from another
provider so let's go a little deeper
into some of the benefits that developer
gets from running cloud run on GK and
and what that means to them so first of
all I was talking about automation
there's one of the key features that we
talked about with regards to cloud run
whether it's an GK or on kubernetes is
auto scaling which means that you as a
developer can ride your application and
be able to respond to unpredictable
usage patterns whether it's a disaster
that suddenly creates a lots lots more
demand on your service or whether Justin
Bieber tweeted about some jeans and your
applicant market marketing application
has to respond to some service much more
or be able to scale much larger audience
of visitors what it also means that
cloud run manages your code and
configuration as unit the benefit of
that is that you have at all point at
the ability to go back to the last-known
State so it's not just the code that was
compiled that's a certain version plus
different configuration and suddenly you
have to change the differences it's a
unit that snapshot whenever you apply a
change to a service that tricks them
together the other thing is that cloud
run underneath on cloud run on G key
underneath is using sto a very powerful
mesh service that in order to make that
accessible to you we expose a very easy
to reason about object model that allows
you to deal with things like routes
management or observability around
metrics that you want to capture so in a
situation of a very common situation for
example when you come to the conference
like this you get excited about
particularly technology you deploy your
application it runs now you have users
great and now you say I want to
change I mean if it was me I would
probably have a bargain ders I have to
fix it but you write a perfect code so
no problem there you want to make a
change but you have active users so how
do you do this so the ability to manage
Easter underneath and manage those
routes reliably allows you to support
things like Bluegreen deployment where
you have a new version of application or
experiments which you can actually start
sending incrementally larger number of
percentage of traffic to this new
version and in top of this also cloud
run on GK is also pluggable what that
means is that it connects very well with
the series of native services offered by
GCP as you know cloud run or stock
driver whatever it may be and Donna has
listed few other ones there but it also
is extendable by our partners and
there's number of them out there the
ones I want to highlight here is get lap
and data dock if you if you've been in
developer space you probably are aware
of those companies all right so enough
with slats are you all ready for demos
you don't seem very excited are you
ready for demos there we go all right so
for our first set of demos we're going
to show you how you can have easy
request-based activation and skill and
demand for this I'm gonna invite Mike
Momsen from Airbus Ariel who's going to
talk about how Airbus is using cloud run
on gke hi guys I'm Mike that's a photo
of me with shorter hair so I'm at a vibe
yeah so yeah like I work as a back in
deaf I'm gonna show all the way that we
can use cloud run to make our systems
simpler yeah so here we go
so like who are we our goal is to be
your one-stop shop for all your spatial
data needs so we have satellite data
from our set of satellites we have a
very massive set of satellites we can
get you satellite data each day down to
50 centimeter it's fantastic data we
also have manned which we're calling
airborne here and when you go and you
see a map online and they claim it's
satellite it's almost always manned
and then we also have drone drones great
for 3d models or very close up
inspection so we have all this together
all on a web browser-based system it's
very simple if you're not a GIS expert
to use we can also bring in data from
our clients or data that's different
than this so we have it all together and
one thing we've been so one of the use
cases that's been great for us for
helping our clients has been like all
these natural disasters so I actually
was in this room yesterday I saw a talk
by a guy from Mayday AI and he said that
70% of the u.s. is at risk for a natural
disaster so there were the fires out
here there's the floods in the Midwest
and there's the Hurricanes out east when
we have a storm like that no one knows
what's happening on the ground it's a
total wreck you can't get through with
cars so to have some sort of data
available allows the first responders to
know what's going on so in this case
there was just a little tropical
depression on the 7th and 8th and then
all of a sudden it became a huge storm
on the 9th it crashed into Mexico Beach
on the 10th and on the 11th we had data
inside our portal for our clients to use
so it's very impressive how we can get
data from a satellite into our system
and in front of our clients in a very
quick fashion this is actually very
important for our clients if we have a
client that's an insurance company if
they see that picture right there they
don't have to send someone out they can
just cut checks and this is very
important to the people that were in
these homes they can start their lives a
lot quicker it also like saves a lot of
money for the insurance company because
they don't need to send out people which
can cost six to eight thousand dollars
just to send out a single person so
helps people in real life and it does
some good for people so I'm going to
show how we do this so this is our
spatial data processing pipeline so
starting on the Left we have raw data
coming in and all the way to the right
we have
our web browser each of those arrows is
a program written by someone like me
wrapped into a docker container with
lots of good code and OS and then on top
of that a ton of yeah Mille so we can
send it up to the Google Cloud I
actually joked that I'm an animal
programmer at this point because I'm
sure most of my lines of code are
actually yeah Mille but that's the way
it's you know it it has worked for us
it's a pretty good system but as you can
see it's pretty complicated I'll just
walk you through what would happen with
a satellite so that would be at the
bottom here if we get satellite data in
these are crazy datasets they're 80,000
pixels by 40,000 pixels and we don't
have to process one of them we have to
process tons of them at a time so it'll
be lots of them coming in and then we
load those into Google Cloud storage and
we have to process those into images
that are things that our map server can
serve up so our clients can see it so
there's lots of steps to get our data
from our source all the way to the
browser it's not terrible but you know
like this is the system we were using at
the top that's vector data so that would
be stuff like parcels and whatnot so I'm
going to show the way that we can
improve this with cloud run so this is
replacing all of the image processing we
don't need all those intermediary files
because we can scale down and up I very
simply we can skip all the
pre-processing serve off of an
individual file so we have one TIFF and
we can use that TIFF for all of our
machine learning we can use that for all
of our spectral analysis and we can use
that for our map server so this makes
our data a lot simpler it's like this is
the way that we think of our data it's a
satellite capture we have one file we
start on Google Cloud Storage and from
there we can do all the things we need
to do with it this is very easy for us
to implement because we already have
everything as docker so we can just
basically send that docker image about
that cloud run and it works if we do
want to try out a new deployment we can
do a blue-green so that's
stick so I mean this is a lot simpler
than that previous slide and I like it a
lot
show us I'm gonna show you guys all
right so this is a demo of that map
Tyler that I was describing so this is
this is actually running on cloud run
and you saw those tiles as they were
loading each one of those tiles is a
request that goes to the cloud run
server that cloud run server sends a
request to GCS and then it gets the data
back and then it recompiles it and it
makes a tile that we can see don't this
might be this might be good for you cuz
you're you know geospatial engineer but
I can't see anything can you please
enlarge and enhance so this isn't CSI so
we can't and do the enhancing but
real-time no but actually because
because we didn't have to pre-process
the image and we could serve straight
off that TIFF that TIFF has a lot more
colors in it and we have to reduce the
amount of colors that go to the browser
so because we didn't have to pre-process
it we can actually change the way that
we show the colors so this is that same
image that I was showing over here but
we did a stretch to it
so previously if we would have messed up
the stretch and this does happen we
would have had a dark image or a light
image but now we can expose to our front
end or to our clients ability to change
the way that they view the image so I
can get in here and I can actually make
this image look way worse so rather than
doing a stretch that goes between 2% and
98%
although from 2% to 70% and it's washed
out and looks terrible but it shows that
we can do on the fly processing and it's
going to change the way that we can use
our whole spatial data processing
pipeline and I'm very excited to take
this and apply it to all the other
arrows that you saw in that previous
slide thanks guys
awesome thanks Mike what I really like
about this demo is that you you didn't
have to you can move away from batch
processing but you also don't have to
design for peak capacity because you
can't really plan for a natural disaster
and until if you're not using something
like serverless you would have to
provision a lot of extra machines but
here when customers want this data this
image data on demand you can do this
scaling and that's really the power of
having a server less developer
experience so if we go back to the
slides
alright so mark in this case Mike had a
container image can you show us what
happens if you only have source good I
guess we I'm gonna do a quick overview
here maybe first can go back to slides
for a second so I can do the demo in a
second here but I want to just kind of
walk you through so a lot of times we
talked about developers just wanting to
write code so you know kind of the get
apps like set up or use case what that
means as the developers are committing
their code and ongoing basis into code
repository and there is a series of unit
tests on their machines and their
integration tests that are running on
against the code repository so whenever
a new commit comes in its executing but
sooner or later the the operators or the
release manager will come in and say
okay I'm ready to to make a new cat and
deploy in your deployment so they will
come in they will create a trigger in
what we're gonna show here is the
integration of cloud build which is
another hosted offering from Google
that's managing the build process we're
going to create a trigger in there
that's going to go through the series of
steps and deploy a new image to cloud
runs so how do % transparently no user
involved all right let's switch back so
what I have here is a clearly for demo
design application unless you in a prime
number of calculating business and who
wouldn't want to be in that that's kind
of all it does you give it a number and
it calculates
I don't know let's do something
something different
great so we got number it's really not
like the application is really not
important here
please don't focus on that what's what's
interesting here a couple things first
of all we use this also as a rest
service so you can you can use it to
test the scalability use cases because
you can pass a larger number which will
consume more CPU but also not something
we're going to do today the part I wanna
focus on is over here what we have is
for demo purposes we injecting the
release tag that was a assigned by the
release manager in repository so that we
can when this entire application travels
to the pipeline I showed you before we
can actually see it so let's take a look
at this application this application
again the application purpose is really
not relevant what we're gonna focus on
is the release management process there
was 46 releases you can see we've been
busy testing this so I asked the release
manager gonna just create a new release
and you know what let's call this
something like a next demo X demo that's
a great idea and next demo and because
this is demo hopefully you do better
release notes than I do in your
production system and when we when we
fire this what actually is happening
here is that cloud run a sort of cloud
built automatically notices this so
let's go kind of deeper into this
process what we have here is a
information about the status of that of
that particular built including the the
repository that it came from but it also
has a has a trigger that we can kind of
interrogate so what happens here is the
triggers set up it indicates where the
repository was so in this case was the
get get a github repo day we went to has
some name that you want to be able to
use there's two different ways you can
trigger this you can trigger it on a
branch created or for qa/qc kind of
purposes but in this case we went with a
tag and the tag has a regex in this case
we release v anything after that
whenever get called build sees one of
the stacks it will build the entire
process and there's a configuration for
but let's let's go over here quickly
history let's take a look at this so
this built configuration has number of
steps and those are defined by you so
you can build simple only test you can
use run a build process and push
repository but what we doing in here is
we're copying the entire source code
we're running a test we're creating and
building an image publishing the image
to the repository GC image repository
we're creating a manifest in order so we
can inject that environment variable and
other configurations that you need and
deploy it and obviously there is a log
following you can access this so
hopefully if everything worked correctly
we can come in here refresh it and you
see my next demo label this happens
transactionally so the requester were
being served by the previous version of
release are being completed before a new
one is being being sent to the user in
response to HTTP requests all right mark
I think you should make this better so I
noticed that when you were in the cloud
build UI you were refreshing to see what
the status is can you have this trigger
yes so as part of our demo again we're
gonna do kind of an add-on process we're
gonna go in and use one of the features
of cloud build which publishes build
status changes into a pops up topic pops
up is the globally distributed it's
simple to use elastic message queue
service offered by GCP and so there is
whenever you have a cloud built in your
project configured it will automatically
create that topic for you so you don't
have to do anything there what we're
gonna do is we're gonna create a very
simple subscription that will watch for
events on this topic and send them to a
to an image or to a notification service
that will relay them to slock if
everything works okay we'll see this
whole thing work automatically so let's
take a look quickly at a we can close
this at a simple notification service
that we're gonna deploy in here so this
notification service among many other
thing is a go application but the two
things to focus on here is it has a
handler so
received a push from a pop subtopic and
really does many different things but on
the end of the day just really extracts
the notification that was there so
strongly type object in not jsut might
get away by simply taking this and
sending to or any at any other dynamic
language and then it sends it to a
sender that that decorates it with a
beautiful slack message with icons and
everything and shoots it over to on a
very end to slock again this this is not
as important so let's go where are we
let's go to a command line what we're
going to do here this is very narrowly
command line but so let me break it down
we're going to deploy this service first
of all we're gonna use g-cloud which is
a CLI that you already common very
familiar with if you're using anything
on G on GCP we're gonna use the run
service and we're gonna deploy an
application I'm calling very fancy pops
up notifications or something like that
the two things that we're gonna provide
is an image path now most of the demos
you have seen for ease of demonstration
so far we're using something like GC our
name or name of the project and name of
the image which is great it will work
except it's very unpredictable because
what is the latest image today might not
be the latest image tomorrow when your
application scales down so I'm gonna use
a sha that is specific to the image so
it is very unique cloudbuilt has an
ability to generate consistent
predictably it predictable images so it
can guarantee that that image is going
to be the same even if you reproduce
that image over and over
so thank thankful thankfully I'm not
gonna have to type it because it's a
very long shot the other thing I'm gonna
provide any here again in a lot of demos
we just simply run some command and it
deploys it by in a real world you have
some configuration so I'm populating
some few information in here so let's
run this so let me make sure I
understand this you wrote your own
custom code that listens on a pub sub
topic and it posts to slack and this is
what you're deploying right now yes so
first of all you notice hopefully you
notice because there a lot of work went
into this deployment was fast like I
just run it and the entire image from
GCR and deployed in fact if you are hit
it some with my application with some
traffic that same performance will be
true for every single new instance of
the application that is pretty awesome
but one thing that we got here two
things we got here that we really care
about is a specific revision name of the
instance that we push we remember to the
example I was talking about before where
you can come back and say you know what
the new deployment I just did not good
some tests did not work let's go back to
last previous known state you can list
those states and you say go and make
this one active but the other thing more
importantly what we got here is a URL my
instance is automatically configured
with a custom domain and with SSL
Certificates so everything is is working
and what are we going to do now
hopefully you can see this we're gonna
create the pops up back to G cloud pops
up subscription create and everything
has to have a nice long name so this is
mine and two things that we need to care
about here
one is we define the topic remember I
told you that cloud built automatically
creates a topic for you so this is
constant name you can always use it in
you there's one of those in your project
and the other thing we're going to do is
we're going to define push endpoint pops
up can work either as a pool when you go
in and attach a client and get events or
it can work as a push so in this case
we're using a push whenever there is a
new tab a new message on a topic a
subscription will be created that will
push that to our service the other thing
I'm doing here worth noting is because I
don't just I don't want you to start
sending events to my notification
service in slack I'm sharing a token
between both of those that allow me to
make sure that only known publishers can
go for it so let's let's run this so
basically this pub sub topic is what's
creating the connection between cloud
build and our cloud rent service that we
just deployed yep so now we have our we
have our image publish service publish
we have our subscription created so
let's go back to the browser
[Music]
marks Prime and we're gonna create a new
release
you've seen this already before so
nothing new in here I can't type sorry I
I don't think it really matters for the
demo but let's go with four how's that
better new one the name is not relevant
for this over here the release number is
the only thing that matters so we're
gonna we're going to publish this and
don't worry I'm not gonna make you go
all the way back to cloud build status
so watch this exciting progress going
we're going to go quickly to slack I'm
using the the key native public Channel
so if you working on a native or
interested in a project you can always
join us but to think you will notice
here is that we've automatically have
published this saying hey I'm working so
what happened is that cloudbuilt said
i've copy i'm starting to work on this i
went in i copied i published new status
called working and that status travel
through pops up all the way to our
simple notification service that really
just decorates nice messages and sends
them to slack and slugs displays this
their other thing that we have is where
the link directly to that build process
so hopefully by then we should be
getting pretty close to being done where
are we right now we are on step one
still so this will this will run through
the exact same process and then
eventually we'll get to the point where
we have here which will publish a hey I
succeeded you can customize this the way
you want it there really there's nothing
fancy in here it's just what we showing
is that you can wire that to very simple
web hooks or services that are connected
to get together do we want to wait for
this to finish how close are there we
done let's see if we have our final
status success I usually get a clap for
this but okay
so the interesting thing is that this
application that listens for these
pub/sub topics and publishes is glue and
this is glue that is typically written
and it functions as a service on a host
it you know say Google cloud functions
but here with cloud run you can run that
glue code really easily in your own gke
cluster yep so can we change the slides
yeah so this is just a very quick
summary of what we've done you've seen
the first one already there pops up
topic is is being configured with this
new subscription you can have n number
of subscriptions so we have clients
listening and pushing and all that we've
deployed a service and the service went
to slack there is number of CI CD
companies in fact if you come to any of
the other cloud run services you will
see for example some of our partners
integrating with this so much you might
not for example say cloudbuilt is not
what I like I like I know Jing connects
or I like gitlab those those partners
have active integrations with cloud run
on GK all right the other thing that
often happens is like in all the demos
because they most need to be simple to
show during the conferences we often
deal with this use case where there is a
one service very simple UI is something
because you have to illustrate but in
the real world you have a situation
where you have to combine things
together so hopefully you're kind of
following like a 12 factor application
development model or you have a series
of micro services that you stitch
together cloud run in addition to what
I'm going to show you also introduced
like I said introduces a service mesh so
you can bind those services in much more
useable manner the example I like to say
is that it's very simple to manage three
micro services when you get to 10 20 100
you you you you can't rely just on your
own
hey I know remember remember the URL
over there or something like that
because they just connect together right
so what we're gonna do here is we're
gonna build our little more real-world
solution I'm gonna deploy a service that
it's doing nothing else just exposing a
rest rest api
for user to request a the service to
identify L logo so we're going to send a
bunch of images and it will tell us what
logo is in the particular image is using
behind the scene vision API which is
part of our ml stack you can use
anything anything else
what we going to do then is we're going
to come in and say okay great vision API
uses credits I don't want the entire
world to use my credits so I'm gonna
from this application with a simple Roth
application which is gonna use Google
OAuth service and I'll expose a nice
visual UI to its are no longer curl
commands but we're gonna use the simple
UI I build this all myself so don't
expect any beautiful graphics there but
if you are really kind of paying
attention you quickly realize that there
is nothing stump stopping somehow I
continue doing this now we have number
of micro services and if you if you use
some of our other services we have that
the situation where you know everything
is exposed to the Internet so in this
case on cloud run what we provide a way
is to deal with that so let's switch
back to a command line and sorry to demo
- command line can you switch the
specific window on my machine alright so
what am I gonna do here I have how big
is this is a big enough I don't think I
can go any bigger than this can people
see it so we're running here is we've
executed simple curl command let's see
what the image looks like so here you're
just this is the first slide that you
just yeah sorry I've walked you through
the entire process we're gonna go back
into kind of Navigators you and I know
this is kubernetes but for a machine
yeah I'm not sure what I know what it is
so what we what we just invoked here is
this service in a step one where we
directly got the result from a vision
API that was in there was managed by the
rest service that we expose by the way
the vision API exposes all other
attributes that I'm kind of just hiding
and disregarding in here but I'm just
bringing the one for demonstration
purposes so let's let's do this let's go
in now and take a look at the demo
application so
simple application and like I told you
not beautiful graphics there but what it
allows us to do is come in here and
authenticate I'm gonna use my personal
one for this is this visible yeah so
what that allows us to do is you know
ask the very same thing in a much more
user-friendly way so you can click the
images populate you can you can paste
your own again the application doesn't
really matter so we have our simple UI
that's forces users to authenticate so
we know who is running great except now
still still no bueno right I can
continue running this directly against
the back-end service so let's come to a
cloud UI what's the wrong window so
basically you you added a UI and you
have a lot of people to sign in but you
didn't protect the service so people can
still get to it directly yeah so I'm
looking at the cloud run UI here you can
do the same thing in a command line but
for I've noticed that we don't show much
of the cloud run UI in dentals so this
is my mission for today
the other thing you will notice here
that I have mix and match of services
you will see some things the running
cloud run on gke
in a particular cluster called next
because I can't be creative anymore or
they running on them managed service the
same interface the same developer
experience that the same operational
experience that you've done before so
let's go into our K logo service that's
on next there's you see the image that
we publish and everything else but one
of the things we can do in here we can
actually come in and very easily you can
do this from a command line by the way
too we can change this to internal two
things will happen let's do no longer
jQuery because they'll be easy let's do
more verbose curl give us a lot of
things but the one thing I really care
about is here are HTTP status by the way
did you notice HTTP too huh I it
upgraded automatically the other thing
that we see here is the status for my
service is now for forest it's not that
we have protected this we have made it
not visible so it's only
accessible in a cluster local now let's
see if our UI continues to run if I can
only find the demo here there we go
let's make a new one
droid there it is that was it so let's
switch the slides maybe quickly I know
it was a lot moving part so I'm gonna
bring a slide here that kind of helps us
understand so what we've done we've
created services I actually added behind
the scene another one because I don't
want you to continue abusing my service
by running the URL now many multiple
times so I'm Lee adding a user service
that using a fire store for persistence
of data very scalable data service very
easy to use and thus metering so I think
I have like hundred queries per user per
day so if you if you are being very
diligent it will probably block you
there eventually but the other thing
we've done is very quickly made both of
those backing services that don't need
to be exposed externally directly we
made them cost your local fancy term for
saying they don't have an external URL
but I do have a URL that can be
discovered by my front UI and connect to
them is yes so basically what you can
see here is this is a more realistic
application where you actually have
multiple micro services you're
protecting your services and you're
making sure that things are production
ready because there's big gap between
what works in demos and what works in
production but we have things available
for both of you for both of those
scenarios for you so what we showed you
was the developer experience for a cloud
run ng ke and you saw when Marc showed
the services tab in cloud run it's
actually the same developer experience
there's just different configuration
options that are available in each
environment and you can mix and match
you could decide well I have a cluster
already I'm gonna use the spare capacity
to do part of my workload I'm going to
put some of it on hosted cloud run you
could change your mind later move it
back it's extremely easy and because
it's all powered by cane native you're
not using a particular API that may not
be available in some other environment
that you're running so your workload is
portable there's another thing that's
portable though
I think it's really important to know it
is your skills as a developer or is the
tech person you know we have a limited
amount of time to learn some new
framework and some new stack and it's
hard to know what thing to learn that's
actually going to be durable it's going
to be useful in multiple environments
and this is one of the things that Kay
native gives you because it's a standard
consistent developer friendly API that
is available in multiple vendors not
just Google Cloud you can know that the
things that you've learned you can use
elsewhere so multiple teams working in
the same company can have a consistent
developer experience so thank you very
much if you want to learn more you can
go to a cloud google.com slash run the
Kay native website is also available now
at K native dev and you can also ask us
questions on Twitter
[Music]